vous avez le sentiment que le parti
socialiste pour ces sénatoriales va
profiter justement du mécontentement des
français en particulier des élus locaux
face justement lève à cette baisse des
dotations à la fin des contrats et des
jouets dans le scrutin je crois que ça
va jouer et je crois que le parti
socialiste veut tenir un discours de
clarté le parti socialiste doit montrer
à quel point des choix qui sont faits il
les conteste et les condamne de ce point
de vue on peut pâtir les textes sont
écrits et déclarations que le parti fait
sont claires de ce point de vue
néanmoins dans l'opinion publique et
parfois même chez nos élus les choses
sont parfois peu comprise en tout cas
apparaissent et l'isi au regard de
certaines divisions et je crois que le
gros nationale d'hier à lui bien remet
des choses des pendules à l'heure